المخاوف من الحرب وايامها التي قد تطول
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
العاصمه الخرطوم ومناطق السودانيه اخرى
اجبرت الكثير من السودانيين على محاولات
تامين مواد غذائيه لتخزينها لكن ما ان سمع
دوي رصاص الذي بدا صباح السبت الماضي حتى
اغلق غالبيه التجار محل لهم وبدون نيه على
ما يبدو لاعاده فتحها طالما بقي لهب
الازمه مشتعلا الشوارع خالتنا الماره
واحتلها الطرفان المتخاصمان بحواجز عسكريه
فاقمت من خطوره مغامره خروج المدنيين من
منازلهم غير المحصنه اصلا من الرصاص
الطائش ورغم ذلك يخرج البعض بحثا عن مخابز
ومتاجر قليله بقيت ابوابها مفتوحه لكنها
بدات تضييق امام شح المخزون فالاسواق
الكبرى بالعاصمه كبحري وام درمان والسوق
العربي والتي تعد المصدر الاول لمد
الاسواق الصغيره يمثل على الاستهلاكيه
اغلقت ابوابها تماما مع مخاوفها من عمليات
نهب محتمله
وكعاده الحروب لا تكتفي باتخاذ الموت
رفيقا بل تسعى لمزيد من الماسي فاحياء
مختلفه محرومه منذ السبت الماضي من المياه
والكهرباء الخاضعه للتقنين حتى قبل بدء
المعارك
وفيما احيى اتفاق الطرفين المتحاربين على
منح المدنيين هدنه انسانيه بعد ظهر الاحد
لتامين حاجاتهم لكنه سرعان ما تبخر بعد ان
عجزت ساعاته ثلاث عن تغيير الوضع مع
استمرار ضوي الانفجارات في الخرطوم
حنان المصري العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات